RYERSEIVCPAC
RAERAT SHOOK
READING THROCOS LVING EVERY CAP1
LIEST NTTOX NEWS INTERVIEW RSE,D
TO SPEAK.
IT VERY MILD-MANNERED
LIE, WHICH H A
PROMOTED, WHICH ANYTHING BUT
HTU'RE NOT GOING TO
UN
>> AND THEN LIMBERHE , AND THEY
DN TERALLY.
>> WRONG.
THE REPORT REFERENCE FROE EN
PRDING ENTIRE
E SPM ICANNST
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION INTO
THE SN
OOU HAE
ER PRESS DOESN'T
LIKEO REALL BECA
TH THAT RA  ITY.PI
YOU
THERE.
>>HOERL COUNT CE BYTTEDFOFAR FO
THE D WAABLE.
FOR OCEE  THE
ASSAULTS, THE BEATIN AND THE
>>FUL.
NO.
INVOLVING
R NANCLO I HADO
SECRARF FEWEHOTIONAL GUARDSMENB
NEWNT'TO C IT.
THAT WOULD BE HE
PEOPLE JAIL.IX
>>E GUTH E NO GUNS.
BASEBALLEAR
IMPBLW HOW NY RIOTERS WERE  WAE
EREVE WAY,'RE
IT, O SHOTY
HAO SHOTN
INNOCENT, NDFUE >>, COHEN
DEE S THROUGH ALL THESE COS SAY.
SPE >>E PERSON THAOT
AN, MILITARY
WOHEAD?
NO REPERCUNSLEBI
IN TE NUMBER NINE.>> OPEN., WI
TEA STREAM OF
B POLICE
OFF
OFFIRSND SPEAKG LIE NUMBER
TEN.
>> THERE WAS ALSO A LOVEE CAPITO
THTO CAPITOL.
>> SO THIS IS THE LOVE FEST OF
>>IE NUMBER 11 INVOLVES THE
ENCE TWE
>> THEY HUNDREDS OFOURS OF TAP.
TAO E THTO WD.
>> FIRST OF ALL,HEHARDLY AN EXO
IN FACT,HET THE CENTER
OF THE THEM.
R ASEING THE TAPES, SLOWLY BUT
CNNF MEE DEMANDING E COURTS.FI2
Y HAVE PEOPLE WHO WALKED
EM, AND IT'S NOT RIGHT.D EY PANF
THEY'RE CONSTRUCTION WORKERS.
, IN MAN
CASES,RENDLE.
EM PEOPLE.
OCCUON HUNDREDS OF
SUSPECTS FREE.
THE ONES ARE CHARGED
ONE OF THE CENTR